I wasn't biology and science major I'm
probably gonna get four right so I have
a minute to do this how many problems
are there 60 so one a second how come
that took me so long to pick that up
this is hard already skip this is crazy
oh my god I remember is this is chump
[ __ ] right here one times 12
get out of here at that nonsense this is
like Kumaon from 5th grade all over
again
Oh dad 12 times they wrote down
something then I distrusted myself I
[ __ ] no that's not it I don't know what
that one is
I forgot how to write numbers ah there's
like no time ooh I'm cooking now oh no
[ __ ] you literally just have to do it in
like the order that you see it this is
when you just gotta go I'm like skipping
a lot of them just cuz I don't know no
[Music]
yeah oh my god this so fast
[Music]
okay I'm happy with that that's great
I felt dumb because I like forgot what
two times it's fine because I don't I
haven't had to do multiplication like
that since third grade
thirty-two out of sixty ain't bad in a
minute in my opinion my parents might
just thank me like five times instead of
20 oh that's still enough but eh that's
better than half the goal is to not
embarrass yourself then I think I
succeeded I mean yeah I could've done
better that heart is very heavy right
now I've wrote 35 now wrote four and
like no you idiot I did not mean to skip
three times safe that's easy that's 24
duh all right I'll take it
11 times zero is not 11 I guess I sell
some things to learn
shout out to miss Hanson they're great
she taught me well you have to know man
you should know your multiplication
tables so you just know how to multiply
divide add and subtract at least that
stuff you've got to know it you've got
to know it Keith's average burger
endorses math